As the years go by, movie fans learn each
and every thing there is to know about their
favorite films.
But sometimes, a single detail or two that
could explain plot holes and dangling plot
threads is missed.
Funny, informative, or downright disturbing,
it's these little known secrets that can forever
change the way you see your favorite movies.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Amazing Details
That Completely Change Popular Films.
Fight Club
Most fans of the Ed Norton/Brad Pitt mind
bender will assume that Fight Club follows
the novel it's based on to the letter.
But the endings are actually completely different.
In the movie, Tyler Durden is killed be the
narrator, forced to watch as the bombs he
planted level skyscrapers, hopefully tearing
down civilization and the economy along with
it.
In the book, things go differently: Tyler
still disappears, but the bombs never blow.
Instead, the narrator wakes up in a mental
hospital he confuses with heaven, eventually
visited by his followers, who are still on
a mission to build a new society.
It changes the message of the movie completely,
but even the novel’s author has admitted
he likes the movie's ending better - so you
shouldn't believe EVERYTHING you read.
The Matrix
Some leaps in logic or suspension of disbelief
are needed for the basic premise of The Matrix,
since computers using people for electricity
doesn't work quite as well as the movie suggests.
But the original plan made a lot more sense,
with Machines using human brains as processors.
That's the reason a human born in the system
could use "mind over matter" to gain control
over The Matrix.
In the end, the idea was a bit too complicated
to explain, so the directors opted for a simpler
premise.
E.T.
The Extraterrestrial
Steven Spielberg's alien movie was a monumental
hit, but the story of E.T. started as something
much, much darker.
The original idea focused on ten evil alien
visitors capable of killing cows with a single
outstretched finger.
One of the aliens, named Buddy, wasn't as
evil as his friends, and wound up becoming
friends with a young boy.
Spielberg eventually realized the story worked
better as a kids' movie, and kept the rest
of E.T.'s race off-screen.
Thankfully, E.T.'s glowing finger didn't instantly
kill the things it touched, either.
Monsters Inc.
The idea for Pixar's monster movie changed
several times over the years, with one version
of Monsters Inc. following George Sanderson,
a “scarer” who couldn't scare kids - until
he met a little girl who faced terror daily
from her older brothers.
As the girl told George to be scary, she overcame
fears of her own.
The story was originally changed, but George
appears just as he would have, as the victim
of constant decontamination.
The Avengers
The Wasp may finally be coming to Marvel's
movie universe, but the superheroine was originally
going to make her debut in the first Avengers
team-up.
Director Joss Whedon eventually decided against
it, and claimed that he loved the heroine
too much, using her - a completely new character
- to bounce off the other Avengers, eventually
making her the biggest star.
In the end, she was replaced by Black Widow.
Which helps explain why the un-superpowered,
quick-witted SHIELD agent was given a spot
on the team without anyone batting an eye.
The LEGO Movie
No one could have known how successful a movie
made of LEGO could be, but the original script
had a completely different take on its star
- and the movie cameos that would appear.
It was originally going to be Indiana Jones
who lost the Kragle to the movies’ villain,
who had to recruit the insanely creative builder
Emmet to save the day.
The duo would have used portals to jump from
worlds based on Lord of the Rings and Star
Wars.
The latter still showed up in the finished
movie, but it missed out on the best moment,
when Emmet and LEGO Indiana Jones came face
to face with LEGO Han Solo - with Harrison
Ford voicing both of his iconic roles in one
scene.
We're keeping our fingers crossed for the
sequel.
James Bond
These days, it's a name famous for deadliness,
charm, secret missions to save the world,
and a love of vodka martinis.
But when author Ian Fleming created 007, his
vision for the secret agent was a different
one: basically, a dull everyman who was always
surrounded by insane villains and dangers.
With that in mind, he searched for the absolute
dullest, most boring name imaginable - and
he found it in author and ornithologist James
Bond.
Bond's most well known book even makes an
appearance in Die Another Day, in the hands
of a more exciting agent than ever intended.
Batman Returns
Tim Burton's Batman sequel may not have been
the universal hit of his original, but the
director's vision of Catwoman and Penguin
are impossible to forget.
They weren't the only famous Batman characters
originally planned to appear, either.
Tim Burton had officially cast actor Marlon
Wayans to play Robin, recruited by Batman
to take down these new threats to Gotham City.
When the movie got too crowded, Wayans was
cut, and replaced as Robin in Batman Forever.
They ahd even manfacrued toys for the Wayans
character.
Audiences never got to see that take on the
Boy Wonder, but Wayans made out all right:
he still got paid for his two-picture deal,
and apparently still earns residuals from
the movie he never appeared in.
Gremlins
Most of the marketing for the movie focused
on the innocent little creature that accidentally
spawns the troublemaking Gremlins, but it's
never explained why something so terrible
could come from a sweet little pet like Gizmo.
The original plan for the movie gives an answer,
since Gizmo winds up as the Gremlins leader,
and the mastermind behind the whole terrifying
attack that follows.
It seems they changed that for the finished
movie - either that, or Gizmo actually was
the villain, and just kept it quiet.
Star Wars
Every fan of the Skywalker Saga has to have
wondered: did Obi-Wan Kenobi really think
that Luke wouldn't eventually find out that
Darth Vader was his father?
It seems weird that the Jedi would force Luke
to hear it from the worst possible person,
but a deleted scene recently surfaced that
helps explain it.
Apparently, it was Yoda who ordered Obi-Wan
to keep it a secret, with a plan to train
Luke in the ways of The Force to defeat Vader,
without him ever learning it was his father
under the mask.
The scene didn't make the cut, but it's a
surprising sinister side of Yoda that shows
he's not as cute or cuddly as he might seem...
Those are the game-changing secrets and story
details we found in hit movies, but which
ones did we miss?
Name them in the comments, and remember to
subscribe to our channel for more videos like
this one.